lieutenant Hopkins says any time you
reach for the shotguns you're either
gonna end up dead or wearing a citation
so I guess it's okay Ralph you did well
in there bud yeah my back man couldn't
ask for a better partner when it first
released in 2011 la Noir was an anomaly
its facial capture tech was an
innovative showcase of animation and its
focus on slower paced interrogation
puzzles widely contrasted the big-budget
shooters of the time six years later the
game has surprisingly managed to make
its way on the switch while a few
sacrifices were made in performance and
graphical fidelity to get la noir
running the ambitious spirit of this
stylistic 1940s era detective adventure
remains can you tell us anything about
this gun Smith & Wesson Model 27
registered Magnum chambered for 357
nickel-plated with pearl grips same gun
used by General Patton you're not
suggesting he's the owner no I'm not you
seem to know a lot about the weapon I
ought to I sold it le noir sprin
suppressant including all its DLC cases
as budding LAPD detective Cole Phelps
you spend the bulk of your time
gathering evidence interrogating
suspects and making accusations Phelps
is a fascinating yet morally flawed
character whose checkered past is
compelling to see unfold as the story
goes on and the cases you solve remain
interesting and well paced balancing
slower
more meticulous investigative moments
with brief shootouts and vehicular and
on foot chases
[Music]
on switch the game controls as well as
it did on previous generation consoles
especially when playing docked with a
pro controller
it also offers motion in touch controls
motion controls allow you to use the
right joke on to control the camera and
physically manipulate objects you pick
up while with touch controls you command
Phelps where to go and what to
investigate by simply tapping the screen
however both control schemes don't feel
as functional as playing with a
traditional gamepad setup while la no
our story and varied pacing are some of
its most exceptional aspects where a
truly shines is in its interrogation
sequences armed with your intellect and
the wealth of evidence you collect
during your investigations questioning
suspects and seeing through their facial
tics to expose their secrets lead to
many of the game's most tense and
captivating moments the facial
animations hold up displaying a level of
realism that's still impressive and with
top-notch performances from its facial
capture actors interrogations are just
as absorbing and believable why did you
do it mr. Cole ooh gage he's in the
Chamber of Commerce he's in with all
those mom's errs he blocked every
proposal I ever put forward [ __ ] piss
and [ __ ] dad he's been trying to ruin my
business for years in a subtle change
from the original interrogation options
have been changed from truth doubt and
lie to good cop bad cop and accuse the
new naming scheme helps to give you a
better understanding of Cole's behavior
towards the suspects testimony which was
difficult to gauge in the original the
renewed context is particularly useful
when a suspect is playing coy or it
makes sense that using the more forceful
bad cop approach would root out more
information if your baby is born in
prison Anna the corrections officers
will take it from you will see your son
or daughter through a metal grate for
half an hour a week however there are
situations where the new terminology
isn't specific enough this is a parent
when responding with good cop where the
option seems to lean more towards
believing the suspect rather than
following proper police protocol despite
this occasional issue interrogations are
consistently rewarding often requiring
critical thinking and sharp judgment to
complete perfectly
la noir is finer qualities are
maintained but it's notable shortcomings
also persist movement is a bit clunky
during shootouts and there are still
plenty of useless filler objects to sift
through during crime scene
investigations but the most glaring
issue lies in the game's recreation of
1940s era Los Angeles which is authentic
but doesn't offer much to do outside of
main missions and random street crime
activities these issues don't do much to
detract from the experience at large
especially considering how well the game
runs visuals have taken a slight
downgrade compared to the original
version sporting new jagged edges
fluctuating textures and noticeably
weaker draw distances and dynamic
lighting effects however these issues
are less apparent when playing the game
undocked where it runs and looks the
best on the other hand framerate
maintains a steady 30 frames per second
only drastically dipping when surrounded
by multiple NPCs or vehicles while on
foot the game consistently performs well
during the moments where it matters like
during investigations interrogations and
car chases
[Music]
even considering La Nora's age it's a
wonder that the game can be played on
switch while nowhere near as technically
striking is seeing doom run on the
console there's still something special
while playing what was once such an
ambitious game on last generation
consoles and the palm of your hand and
the game lends itself well to the
platform the bite-sized length of
missions make it a great fit for playing
on-the-go if sharp visuals in higher
framerate are huge factors in your
enjoyment then you're better off playing
la Noir on ps4 and Xbox one which sport
added bells and muscles that elevate the
game's performance but if you're charmed
by the idea of experiencing it portably
then LA noire on switch comes
recommended it may not work the best
under pressure but it's well worth
replaying or experiencing for the first
time on Nintendo's Convertible console
this is your chance don't fail me
[Music]